the college student loan crisis has
pissed everybody off we're all sick of
it we the taxpayers are sick of being on
the hook for 1.6 trillion dollars in
guaranteed student loans yes we're on
the hook for cuz a few people that owe
it don't pay it the taxpayer picks up
the bill that's how this works and oh by
the way if it's forgiven the taxpayer
picks up the bill so you getting out of
your student loans doesn't mean that the
nation got out of your student loans
doesn't mean that there's still not a
1.6 trillion dollar drain on the economy
so it sure has brought up a lot of
discussions about the value of college
and an importance of a university
education and the stupid stuff and the
illegal stuff that people are doing in
order to get their kids into school
we've got the Hollywood elites that you
know bought their way into ridiculous
situations try to get free school you
know kids that are supposed to be on the
rowing team and aren't and all that
garbage just straight-up fraud and go to
jail don't pass go now we're having to
deal with the district attorney and it's
all in the spotlight and tabloid
headlines and so here comes another
group of fraudulent misfits in the
culture dozens of college students from
well-to-do families now this didn't say
millions it said dozens it's all over
the news as if this is a an epidemic
plague on our culture it's not it's just
another handful of crooks dozens of
college students from well-to-do
families may be getting money reserved
for poorer families thanks to a legal
loophole they are giving up custody of
their own children
what's scum this tactic is legal but
ethically questionable do you think says
Andrew Borst the director of
Undergraduate Admissions at the
University of Illinois
chief among his concerns financial aid
money is limited money we give to one
student is money not to going to another
student well besides that it's fraud
ethically you're not poor you shouldn't
be taking poor people's money that was
set aside for poor people to go to
college that's what a Pell Grant is it's
for poor people people that don't have
money I'm afraid if I save too much
money my kids won't qualify for
financial aid will no crap I'm afraid if
I get a job I don't qualify for welfare
no kidding doofus what kind of morons
are you people this is unbelievable
here's how the scheme worked families
near Chicago oh here's a shock Thank You
Chicago chase you mean there's financial
problems in Illinois this is new news
would give up legal guardianship of
their children to relatives or friends
students would then file for financial
independence which effectively opened
the door to financial aid that would
have been able they would not have been
able to access while under the legal
care of their parents who had the
freaking money to send their kid to
college the very University of Illinois
started investigating after high school
counselors from quote fairly wealthy
neighborhoods had called in to inquire
about low-income orientation programs
they were unfamiliar with the university
dug deeper and found a pattern of
students entering into legal
guardianship though they were still
supported by their parents thank you
well I'm glad they dug it out so it's
just like saying I'm gonna move all of
my grandmother's million dollars out of
her name so she qualifies for Medicaid
nursing home we're gonna move it out of
granny's name how can we get the assets
out of granny's name so the nursing home
doesn't get it see that's called welfare
fraud they have the ability to look back
five years and undo your illegal
transfers of wealth for you to illegally
qualify for welfare nursing home called
Medicaid nursing home the only way you
get free nursing home
is you're on welfare the only way you go
to college and the government pays for
it based on your income is based on the
fact that you don't have any money
you're poor I've been poor I know how I
feels I'm not mad at you if you're poor
it's not poor and shaming it's not what
I'm doing
it's not in fact I'm quite up quite much
taking up for the people that qualify
for these things legitimately if you
qualify for a Pell Grant legitimately
take it I'm fine with that go to college
it's wonderful then maybe the next
generation you won't qualify this is
awesome but wealthy parents legally
disowning their children so they can
qualify for need-based financial aid
unethical it should be illegal if it's
not if it's unethical at a minimum I
mean that's like a slam dunk but illegal
I don't I was illegal but it should be
this is just it ought to be just like
these you know these Hollywood
socialites who you know paid their way
for their kid to get into school this is
just nuts you guys it's just nuts listen
yeah no one likes it when the system if
someone busts the system and rigs it
against why it was put together it makes
all of us get our back up because we all
believe in justice at some level now
some of you believe if you can screw
someone you should be able to and you
can get away with it but most of us have
a sense of Honor a sense of decorum a
sense of ethics we don't treat other
people - I would never think of that
I'll give you another example in the
state of Tennessee you can get $3,000
per year under the HOPE scholarship if
you're an in-state student going to an
in-state school that money is provided
by the people who lost the lottery the
lottery in Tennessee generates billions
of
dollars and has paid billions of dollars
out in hope scholarships I hate the
lottery the lottery is a tax on poor
people and attacks on people who can't
do math it's a horrible thing I
campaigned against it when it was up for
a vote I knew we were going to lose
people wanted the lottery you got the
lottery the vast majority of people who
play the lottery are in lower-income zip
codes the HOPE scholarship program in
the state of Tennessee in the state of
Georgia and other states who do the same
thing is 100% people who can't do math
and poor people sending middle class
people and rich people kids to college
can't stand it
I've been a loud mouth about it for
20-something years I hate it now how
ethical would it be when my kids went to
the University of Tennessee for my kids
to take the HOPE scholarship money I'll
be completely unethical
it'll be so hypocritical would be
unbelievable so no Ramsey kid of mine my
three went to the University of
Tennessee my three graduated from the
University of Tennessee received any of
the Tennessee lottery scholarship money
if I'm gonna preach against it and say
how horrible it is that the government
has institutionalized taxing poor people
and stupid people these are the only
people that play the lottery if we're
going to tax these people if I'm against
that
how wrong would it be how hypocritical
would be for me to accept that
scholarship from my own kids course I
didn't take it folks we have to have
some ethics we have to have some honor
we have to have some dignity you know
there has to be a sense of decorum out
there and you know this is not a
widespread epic thing this is a handful
of stupid people almost all the other
article I said read on this there's
almost all through one law
so we ought to go in dis bar those
lawyers and we ought to you know we
ought to investigate whether or not this
is actually technically welfare fraud
you know at least put up a couple of
these people's names on the front pages
of paper embarrass the crap out of them
for being this gun that they are at a
minimum it's not an epidemic though what
is epidemic is what's always been
epidemic there's always a crook out
there in the pile somewhere and it just
shows up and it becomes very emotional
around the subject we're all pissed off
about like student loan debt